M  i  c  h  a  e  l   V  s  a  u  c  e  here and the earth is actually...
FLAT :3
Don't believe me?
Take it, Pewdiepie.
What if the Earth is in fact flat...
and science has been wrong all along?
Thank you, Pewdiepie. There you go. There you have it the earth is actually flat.
C'mon
*Ga*
Gravity, if gravity is real, then how come I can't see it.
Huh :3
Where is it?
I'm still looking... If Isaac Newton was so smart, then how come he's
DEAD
3:)
All these Pseudo-intellectuals
...so blindly biting into what the word of "science" is telling them, believe that the earth is round...
Like a BOWL :3
Well if Earth is round like a ball...
Then why are cars like this...
And not like this? :3
EHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
The earth is flat you may think *ha ha* that's a meme oh no [x4]
it is not a meme :3
It is sciency...
FACT :3
My...
My guy B.o.B The Rapper tweeted the cities in the background...
...are approximately 16 miles apart. Where is the curve? Please explain this.
Yes of course B.o.B here is...
Exp... [stutter]
Providing extremely solid evidence. I can, I can definitely make out what it says in this picture.
This is irrefutable evidence :3
I don't understand why we're even talking about this. Where is the curve?
TYPICAL
POLITICAL
Jumping on anything
Train wagon, Neil deGrasse Tyson just had to butt into the conversation.
Polaris is
gi-gi-gi-gi-gi [???]...
Silly Neil...
You don...
You don't know what you're talking [laughs]
The completely unlikable chipmunk Tila Tequila joining the conversation as well
I will stop my Flat Earth Talk if someone could send me a goddamn photo of the horizon with a curvature
That's right, if it, if I don't see a photograph of a curve
then
ehhhh
everything else is completely...
[Can't caption this satanic gibberish]
If earth isn't flat, why are shoes like this and not like this?
HMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
If earth isn't flat
Why can Pewdiepie's chair do this, but not this...
OH YEAH
BUT CAN YOU DO DIS? :3
[lmao]
REEEEEEEE!!!
If earth isn't flat then why am I wearing headphones when there's no audio
[Alien noise]
If Earth isn't flat, why a computer mouse like this...
And not like this?
HMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMMM
If Earth isn't flat
Why are cars like this and not like diamond mine carts?
Can we stop wasting our...
TIME?!?!
NASA is not spending enough money on space exploration
It's all been taken over by corperation
...but the government needs to thrive
The government was first
Were we not the first ones on the moon?
Well, how could we... Coz the moon is literally just a pizza slice...
If Earth is flat
Then why titties like these round and voluptuous and not like these
Flat like a "tay sway." Oh listen to this one g-gay sons, if Earth is flat
Then why are rainbows like this huh then not like this? Huh? Your move,
LGBTQ community.
HMM. We've heard the answer from the science community
But what about the LGBTQ community?
*HUH* [laughs]
If Earth is flat... then why your mom look like this and not like this
:)))))))))))
*attempts laughing, triggering a coughing fit*
If Earth is flat why am I like this
boooo boooooo
And not like this?
Hmmmm [His face's cute right]
If earth was flat
cats would have pushed everything off by now...
Some silly girl in bikini says
UUH Excuse me
Have you not seen this photo? Excuse me this photo is evidenced by itself. The Flat Earth Society
has members all around the globe I mean on all on the pizza slice
We are it's all on the flat globe, glub. It's a flat globe shut
Shhhhhhhh, shhhht uuuuuhg
Wonder why the dinosaurs all disappeared huh well okay?
Well well
They all went to space of course, silly
Science community. If the earth is round, how do you explain this? Huh?
checkmate NASA
Maybe you need to spend some more money on..
Actual intellectuals
Someone should make an anime where the planets in our solar system are cute anime girls attending school
and there's a running gag where Earth-Chan is self-conscious about her smaller chest to which she constantly responds I
am NOT flat
everybody called me flat waaa!
Don't believe what they say senpai you are not flat
see this is what I'm talking about if the earth is round and
voluptuous, then why is Earth-chan so flaa...
rrraahh
Neither flat or round there are people who believe earth is don't know how to shut the fuck up Jesus Christ
*clap*
It's time to rate the meme everybody
It gets it gets a pizza slice... one
But a really good one that is not my that is not microwave
The next meme is also another older meme, but I need 10 minutes, so let's just get right
into it
Crying Markiplier memes yes
[music plays]
It's so sad
It was this song is so sad by itself, but you add a crying Markiplier to the corner, and it is instantly
The tragedy of our generation I cannot hold withhold the tears
As you can tell by my teeth
*heads up, headphone users*
*Piano music booms in*
[Music (minecraft parody) starts]
don't jump...
noooOOOO
*overdramatized sobbing*
*coughing fit*
You can put crying markiplier over literally anything
And it will turn the happiest thing into sad cause there's nothing more sad than a crying Merkiplier oh
No aho
Adding a cry Markiplier is basically the equivalent of a sad piano, you can't just not cry
Ohhh
The crying Markiplier meme, I mean we of course so sad because
Who would purposely cry on camera I?
I would never do that
I just have too much testosterone in my body that I would never allow myself to cry in front of an audience
When there's a camera present
Whenever I do have to cry, I make sure there's no cameras around me. Thank you very much
I have never cried on camera, and I never will and that's why I laugh at this crying Markiplier meme. Thank you
Oh
Come on, that's too sad. So sad this meme
This meme is so sad. I'm rating it so sad. It's gets a so sad rating
Meme review. Next meme comes from other YouTuber Steven Crowder
He has a series on youtube where he debates other people on controversial topics
Here's one where he says male priviledge isa myth
Change my mind. with this photo in mind that can so easily be altered beautiful memes came out of it
Just beautiful memes. pee is stored in the balls. change my mind
Your wife is trash change my mind. This meme will be forgotten in a week change my mind. Now, this is a great meme
It's gonna transcend
All other memes it's stronger than the Ugandan Knuckles meme. That's for sure traps are not gay change my mind
Now this is some really controversial topics we're getting into now.
Jar Jar Binks is a sith lord. Change my mind
Your mom gay
no u
Yeah, this meme is definitely gonna be dead.
*Laugh/Cough*
But can you do this?
Change my mind.
For only $399.
That's a-
Meme. Review.
Next one please.
Oh!
It would seem that we are done